vanessa bryant shows a united front with
daughter natalia and close friends
sierra and monica as she enters the
courthouse and seeks justice for her
late husband kobe bryant and daughter
gianna each day is a struggle and i
think
one of the greatest aspects of our
friendship which has spanned now for
almost 11 years
almost 12.
it's been
really really important to just simply
be there the ladies arrived together on
monday natalya sierra and monica were
all black ensembles while vanessa donned
a white button-down shirt and black
skirt they made a powerful entrance
walking in hand-in-hand
it's the third week of trial in
vanessa's lawsuit against los angeles
county over graphic photos taken and
shared by officers from the helicopter
crash site that killed kobe their
13-year-old daughter gigi and seven
others in 2020 through the tragedy
monica and sierra have stuck by the
family's side i'm just wondering because
i know that you're also part of vanessa
bryant's village and
just how without like giving any
confidence but how is she doing how are
you guys helping to hold and lift her up
you know right now whatever
she's feeling each day
is not something any of us will ever
understand that level of pain that level
of heartache also respected her privacy
you know people have been reaching out
for a very long time but she's always
been a private person and so being there
i've just enjoyed the kids i've enjoyed
watching them grow i literally believe
the baby is the happiest baby i have
ever
come in contact with
bb the dancing machine is i mean it's
just pure joy and
you can see
even in the heartache they are the
greatest blessing and they are the
greatest gift that he left but as a mom
i've never seen the pain like the pain
of losing a child so we try to keep her
covered she has an amazing village and
sierra she's one of natalia's biggest
supporters the singer had a proud auntie
moment when natalya a student at usc
made her met gala debut listen nani is a
star
she knows what she's doing and i'm so
proud of her she had her american vogue
cup teen boat cover and she's just
rocking it she's in college now i'm the
proud aunt so
she doesn't need any notes she's got
this
as the bryants move forward vanessa
never misses a chance to celebrate
special occasions including what would
have been the late nba star's 44th
birthday vanessa shared this sweet
throwback photo with kobe writing happy
birthday baby i love you and miss you so
much
natalia also gave a shout out to her dad
simply writing happy birthday daddy what
have you learned about how to be strong
and continue and succeed i mean honestly
i've learned the most just from each
other
i think just being able to rely on each
other and be there for each other has
been like the biggest inspiration
[Music]